I'm going to introduce us. So, my name is Alex Kelly and I'm sitting here with Sherrie
Maness, um, is that? That's how you pronounce your last name? Yeah, mhmm. My name is
Alex Kelly and I'm sitting here with Cheri Maness and it is April 2,
2015 and we're here at Lifestyles and recording an
Oral History for Visible Lives Oral Histories of the Disability Experience for the New
York Public Libraries' Visible Lives Project.
So, I just want to start out by asking you, Sherrie, if you could tell me a little bit about where you
come from.
Texas, yeah, I was born there since I was a little kid. And I have my
Grandma, my Mom, and my sister and especially my
especially my Dad too. [noise from mic being repositioned] OK and um, I'm just going to turn up the level.
I mess up or now? There we go, perfect. So, if you could
ah tell me a little bit about what you remember about Texas
ahhh, I used to see my Dad a lot and it used to be warm down there and my mom
I love my mom, so
So, I see my grandma sometimes and my Aunt ?Gwen
Yeah. I miss them a lot. And
what was it like to move to Staten Island? Ah, we didn't have ?service down there in Texas
so we came New York. First we came, lived in Brooklyn and then we came up here in Staten Island.
Right.
And tell me about what school was like for you. Did you go to which
grades did you go to in Texas.
Ahh, a lot of schools in Texas. Maybe a few, I was young. And maybe
ah, when I came up here my first school was Brooklyn. H.I.C.
Okay. Then I started New York, then Wagner, then I went to ?Hunterford that's my last school
last school. OK. Yeah. OK, So what was a middle school like?
It was good, like, you know my teacher from ?Hunterford
?Hunterford used to teach me a lot of stuff from, from the
the war and stuff and the fighting. The people
killing when they wanted America or something. I remember, yeah.
Um, and I'm going to ask you some questions that Diane prepared
So, if you could tell me a little bit about what makes you different from other individuals?
I don't know I don't look to different.
Sometimes I have a scar on my stomach from I was
surgery as a little kid. I used to choke on food so I was different
Like, when I was a little kid, I had surgery right here [background noise]
I couldn't like, like I couldn't talk, I was a little kid
kid and they taught me. And, when I was a little kid, I had surgery took a
while to chew and eat, stuff like that. So people don't
think I'm different cause I don't look different cause if I was different, they would know, you know
mhmm
So, do you live it.
Do you live at home? I live in a group home.
Oh OK, ok. I see my mom and I see my one week
on the weekend and I see her sometimes, sometimes. I have people in my group home
Yeah, I have like, I was number 7. They have like
like 3 downstairs and almost 6 upstairs, or something like that
They take care really well of me.
Where I live. And tell me about the other people of the group home, do you have friends there?
Joe, my friend,
I have a crush on him. I have like Jenny and
Kathleen and John
and you know, Robert too and Billy and the staff too.
Great, great. So do you guys, what do you guys do for fun there?
We play bowling sometimes we watch T.V.
We play bowling, we play BINGO and stuff that, we play
BINGO and stuff like that.
And, um, What do you like about yourself?
I like to see my sister and I have a niece and. I really see
here today. Wednesday and I can see
me every day she start crying.
And crying like you know. I miss her. Tell me more about her
weight issue right.
She's like my sister and I share a hanker if you like to pray
and cry when I leave when she beats me. Yeah
yeah.
What about. Things in life sometimes that you just like.
That you don't like and sometimes people find a group like that right in your
house sometimes life right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
yeah. He's richer.
So. Do you consider your life difficult at all. No
. What are some of the favorite your favorite games that you like to play
.
Being dogs.
Yes. Who has been the most important
person in your life.
For you. To take my mom to take care of you
. OK. My mom. When. My dad and I had me I
used to be an effort to have one. Mom taught me how to
walk again. Yeah. I don't. Know how I work. So she
taught me and she took care of me. And I get a way how
she took care of the kid.
Can you tell me some of the most lessons that your mom taught you.
He taught me how to walk again walk in a hospital and she
take care of me like she is my mom right here is my mom and
.
Her. Best Mom like. That.
So what happened in the hospital.
And. I was a kid. Surgeons I don't you know what. Yeah
yeah the scurry of my stomach. Yeah and. I was a kid I
. Used to choke on Fury a lot then. TB
surgery I can't go I can't really go up we have second it's like I just felt like
that again. So I can't really go up you know like when I get sick I
just came. Here. And.
My mom. Really helped me in my life I love her.
No she isn't she's quite her job because she liked
Brooklyn. So maybe Sam is C O one week.
Here. So.
What are some what are some lessons that you feel like you've taught other people a group
. Home or. Any family members.
Maybe been nice to people. That have learned not to be mean you know
. I've been taught. That people are very nice to
people or am. I to. Have a friend just like from
has a nice like he's thirty two years old and he sometimes you know it's a
son he said these days and now. Has to talk to him like
sometimes like he's a friend.
Yeah. Yeah I see them on the immigration bill.
Yeah.
So a. Famous poet Ralph Waldo Emerson once wrote that the
only person you are destined to become is the person you decide to be
. Who have you decided to be in your life
. I say like I think side too. I think when I get
older when I. Want to plant Mind you when I can maybe
kids maybe and I decide Lammy doing it over there.
What do you want to do when you get older. I won the first set of
bakery and. Best to. Kirk baby at my good job.
Like.
Me finish. The sentence. I
draw my strength from. The.
Pain.
And as we know what would you like people to know about
individuals. That are like yourself.
That this point to disappearing and then. Trying myself
I was born so I was born that way you know. And. And I
. Don't look different. People. Look at me. Like you do you
. Think people think that they think I don't personally people
not just.
Here. Was there a point in your life that you realize that you had a disability
. Congressman I think you know the baby baby I
was born I didn't have a lot. Believing in stuff. Like. That
day to take him he won't. Make a dent. Headline here to please I.
Want to meet. Him.
And have folks here have you.
So how did your mom talk to you about it then she when she got older she
told me that in the stuff like breathing. Yeah I don't know
baby baby. You know.
And are you seeing one thousand nine hundred to finish high school. Yeah and I
see twenty two now. OK OK great.
So what tell me about high school and that was a great time I missed the
free lunches the lunch the right pay for much is now
and maybe like I like the free lunches and missed that really missed
in the free lunches.
And what do you what are you doing now.
And nutty have them working here lifestyles. Oh OK OK what do you do.
Lifestyles.
I make stuff in the store. It's actually. A Maybe
. Like. I do push
on that.
And what if you had the perfect the perfect job in your
life what would it be.
Maybe too close as I like that. Like. Really.
Like I'm sure so I'm like oh I can go to seen and
liked and made stuff like that but be fair.
Cartoons like I like to draw it. Maybe a day at the beach for
pitches I like to do it. And I like to do like
Julie what are what are some record to tell you I know the top
that's my favorite show like this ask the black haired side there are good
guys. That's my favorite thing in the world. Right. And though I did to
my plea for. PIKE. Question. Like he's cute
. Kid. And. I just want people to realize that
this is great and I can't change that you.
Know. Have you ever
. Has anybody ever bullied you mean like my mom say one time I
went to McDonald's psychos and playing around. With some twitch me down like I have a kid and no
. One here is I and I swing persecuted
right in there like I don't know if I got so it was right for
me and that kid it doesn't mean a person. Like pushed me down like that. Mom
came out there to stop them.
And what would you tell a person. I know you know what I was the kid I was like that long time
ago my lungs didn't turn red said Tommy. So it would be like I was
and was.
Is there anybody in your life other than your mom. But it's been a mentor for
you
. Like really nice My sister she's my sister. She's.
She's like my sister has a dick and a big sister. Says. She is my. Sister
. And I pray that her.
Dad. Tell me about.
Where you want to travel outside exam maybe
to Texas maybe again maybe Texas. Is a
Broadway. Show.
You. What do you miss about Texas and sometimes only one time
. And distance and then I don't go to winter and spring I
went down to Times maybe kinda summer and even rain sometimes in summer.
What do you like that Sam I do like the broken toe
putting spy here parking spot like you
. And your group on his tummy and
stays here. Sharon
. So I doubt my own. Case how do
you decorate your room when. I did.
Like. Like a proposed laws like that in
the conversation. Oh. Well let's have a fish which I
. Really like about fish yesterday morning attending
that same morning talk to me saying.
I come home and see everyone and I think fish that
. Have you had any other fish. I did like to see one again an
easy. They got right over the coastal viewing passed away like please
you know.
But you have anyone else.
Is there anything that you want to make sure that other people who are listening to this years and years
and years from now now that you hear.
What do you what do you want them to know I want to know you can't change when you're born you can't
chase to a new born is disappearing. This happens you know
. With the family genes telling them you just can't change it.
When is that was there a point in your life your own life that you realize that.
So now these people realize my mom told me
and shocked you know I didn't know I killed my headaches and turns on
. To Tiger X.. Yeah I get headaches head
to toe on on I do take place. And.
So. You were shocked when your mind. Yeah I
shocked what did you say that. Really was a shock
.
It's easy. When you're. You know if you have children why do they
worry you know. Pastor salaam to children one day what do you want them to
know about your life. Doing. The.
Best like I like to do right and stuff. Maybe if I had a son with him
. Like when he and I didn't hear that Grandma you
crave.
Here. Great. Well is there anything else that you want to say that I would ask you
know I'm OK.
I'm depressed stop. Thank you so much. Was wonderful getting to be here today.